[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna bereich ist herzlich willkommen
an diesem freitag mit sport von norbert
lehmann gut bei unserer familie und den
wichtigsten themen des tages
schwere waffen für die ukraine der
kanzler erklärt sein zögern es dürfe
keinen atomkrieg geben sagt er eine
militärische konfrontation mit russland
wolle er unbedingt vermeiden
russland nennt das ziel der laufenden
offensive der don was im osten und der
gesamte süden der ukraine sollen erobert
werben in mario pohl werden massengräber
ausgehoben
aus der nordsee statt aus russland eine
bohrplattform soll vor borkum erdgas
fördern umweltschützer und inselbewohner
sind dagegen
nachdem die kritik an ihm nicht abreißt
hat sich kanzler scholz jetzt nochmal
genauer zu seiner zurückhaltung bei der
lieferung schwerer waffen an die ukraine
geäußert er tue alles um eine eskalation
zu verhindern die zu einem dritten
weltkrieg führen könne sagte scholz
waffenlieferungen auch thema bei der
baltikum reise von bundesaußenminister
in bernburg heute besuchen litauen danke
panzer berichtet
deutschland führt den nato gefechts
verband dort an schon kurz vor
kriegsbeginn wurde er aufgestockt auf
rund 1600 kräfte 1000 davon deutsche zu
einer weiteren aufstockung beim nato
gipfel ende juni sei deutschland bereit
so baerbock heute der einsatz ihr
garantiere europa sicherheit mit blick
auf die ukraine werde man zudem den
druck auf russland weiter erhöhen auch
mit noch schärferen sanktionen
deutschland hat hier eine besondere
verantwortungsvolle rolle bis die
ukraine wieder frei und sicher ist ein
waffenstillstand um jeden preis kann es
nicht geben einen diktat frieden werden
wir nicht akzeptieren
allein die ukrainerinnen und ukrainer
entscheiden über ihre zukunft so ähnlich
äußerte sich kanzler scholz im spiegel
zu kiews wunsch fortdauern schweres
bundeswehr gerät zu bekommen das dann
nach und nach ersetzt werde sagte er
dagegen spreche die notwendigkeit das
bündnisgebiet jederzeit verteidigen zu
können das ist eine schwierige abwägung
die wir gemeinsam mit unseren partnern
ständig treffen müssen denn die
bedrohungen des nato gebiets durch
russland besteht dass putin atome drohe
für den fall dass deutschland panzer
liefere bestätigte scholz nicht zitat es
gibt kein lehrbuch für diese situation
indem man nachlesen könnte ab welchem
punkt wir als kriegspartei wahrgenommen
werden cdu csu bekräftigten derweil ihr
vorhaben nächste woche im bundestag
einen antrag einzubringen für die
lieferung schwerer waffen da es hierfür
eine überparteiliche mehrheit gebe
kritik von der spd was wir nicht tun
sollten ist hier in politisch
parteitaktische spiele zu spielen
parteitaktisch versuchen profit zu
schlagen aus einer brutalen situation
wie sie gerade in der ukraine ist nein
es geht um die sache dort werden ein
mensch frauen vergewaltigt zivilisten
ermordet gefoltert es ist nicht nur ein
rechtswidriger
angriffskrieg es ist ein
zivilisationsbruch sondergleichen und
der muss gestoppt werden und er kann
sowie russland ihnen führt nur mit
schweren waffen gestoppt werden der
gestern von der bundesregierung
angekündigte ringtausch von panzern mit
slowenien reichen nicht ähnlich sieht es
die jüngst schon sehr kritische
vorsitzende des verteidigungsausschusses
von der fdp diese idee hatten meine
kolleginnen und kollegen im ausschuss
bereits vor drei wochen aber wir müssen
darüber hinaus schauen gibt es trotzdem
noch mehr was wir möglicherweise liefern
können kommt es zum von der union
geplanten antrag samt namentliche
abstimmung wird die nächste
bewährungsprobe für die ampel
er lassen wir das ganze mal einschätzen
von theo koll kann die abstimmung für
kanzler scholz politisch gefährlich
waren
nun sie ist in jedem fall momentan nicht
kalkulierbar das parlament ist noch in
der osterpause und damit ist doch kein
klares mehrheits bild erkennbar aber
hinter diana der union dass die grünen
und die fdp mehrheitlich oder sogar
geschlossen für die lieferung schwerer
waffen stimmen würde davon glaube ich
getrost in fragezeichen setzen natürlich
gibt es sehr präsent die kritiker der
regierungslinie und auch der designierte
generalsekretär der fdp macht jetzt
druck aber die ampel linie wird ja im
bundessicherheitsrat von allen drei
parteiführungen mitgetragen und die
ampel parteien haben fast 100 stimmen
mehr als die opposition es müsste also
viele abweichender ampel stimmen für den
unionsantrag geben interessant dürfte
sein wie sich die fdp auf ihrem morgigen
parteitag verhält und in jedem fall hat
die ganze debatte den kanzler beschädigt
die geheimniskrämerei über die lieferung
die unterschiedlichen begründungen warum
was nicht geht vielen kritikern fehlt es
schlicht an einer raumfüllenden kanzler
präsenz die in einer solchen krise nötig
wäre dankeschön theo koll und
was genau andere nato staaten tun zur
unterstützung der ukraine im kampf gegen
die russische offensive und welche
waffen sie liefern einen überblick
darüber finden sie bei zdf heute und in
der zdf- heute
seine angriffe setzt russland
währenddessen mit unerbittlicher härte
fort ein befehlshaber der russischen
streitkräfte nannte heute das ziel der
zweiten phase des militäreinsatzes
nämlich die vollständige kontrolle über
den don was im osten der ukraine und
über den kompletten süden bis zur
republik moldau ein ziel für das die
menschen in den von moskau beanspruchten
gebieten bitter bezahlen hier im kehl
acht wochen gewalt acht wochen
zerstörung acht wochen tod und leid der
krieg hat kleine städtchen in lehre
ruinen kulissen verwandelt das ist der
ort wo wiesen umkämpften osten direkt an
der aktuellen frontlinie die meisten
bewohner sind geflohen eine handvoll
gestrandete hat einen letzten
rückzugsort gefunden im palast der
kulturen im keller
irgendwann nach zwei wochen krieg musste
ich aus der wohnung raus das dach kaputt
es regnete rein die wände waren feucht
in so einem haus kammer nicht bleiben
kein gas kein licht kein wasser
vom leid der menschen ist im russischen
staatsfernsehen nichts zu entdecken auf
dem weg zum feind werden hier die panzer
begeistert eskortiert und der front
gelingt dann der durchbruch
die waffen des westens werden zur beute
dazu passen auch die russischen
meldungen aus mario pohl in der
strategisch wichtigen metropole mit den
gigantischen azoff stahlwerk gab es eine
martialisch inszenierte siegerpose
tschetschenische kämpfer sie hätten die
stadt den hafen und auch das stahlwerk
erobert doch die militärische lage ist
unverändert in den tiefen des
geschundenen industriekomplexes harren
weiter zivilisten und ukrainische
kämpfer aus die ultra nationale azoff
brigade gibt nicht auf
solange wir hier sind es mario pohl
unter ukrainischer kontrolle mario pohl
wird immer ukrainisch sein egal was sie
sagen die kämpfe gehen weiter sinnlos zu
kommentieren was russische faschisten
sagen sie lügen immer
jenseits aller propaganda top
unbarmherzig der krieg ohne klare
informationen etwa in lima hier brennt
an krankenhaus getroffen von russischen
granaten twittern augenzeugen
uno-vertreter sammeln seit kriegsbeginn
alle hinweise auf mutmaßliche verbrechen
heute ein ernüchterndes zwischenfazit
die russische armee hat bewohnte gebiete
geschossen und bombardiert zivilisten
getötet krankenhäusern schulen zerstört
taten die sich als kriegsverbrechen
erweisen können
58 tage krieg nun endet in der ukraine
und in russland die karwoche ein
orthodoxes osterfest im zeichen der
gewalt
und in der ukraine ist unser reporter
dominic löschmeister dominik warum
scheitert es ständig diese
zivilbevölkerung aus mario pohl
herauszubekommen durch flucht korridore
die straßen seien nicht sicher sagt die
ukrainische regierung auch heute keine
flucht korridore das problem ist mario
pohl ist von den russischen truppen
umzingelt das heißt wenn die busse rein
und raus wollen müssen sie durch
checkpoints diese fahrt kann tage dauern
hinzu kommt dass die ukrainische seite
den russen vorwirft diese busse zu
beschießen moskau widerspricht dem
letztendlich ist es so dass die menschen
in der stadt auch die schwierigkeit
haben zu diesen bussen zu kommen denn
wenn das beschuss gibt müsste man den
keller verlassen oder den bunker
verlassen das sind frauen und kinder und
das ist eine zusätzliche gefahren wir
hatten in der vergangenheit auch immer
wieder zivilisten die gestorben sind
durch beschuss weil sie zu diesen bussen
auch wollten moskau hat jetzt nochmal
für diese stahlwerk eine feuerpause
angeboten wenn die ukraine sicher geben
doch danach sieht es nicht aus aus der
ukraine dominik löschmeister dankeschön
deutschland will ja wegen des ukraine
krieges möglichst schnell ersatz für
russische gaslieferung finden vor der
insel borkum in der nordsee bietet sich
so eine alternative im grenzgebiet mit
den niederlanden schlummern 60
milliarden kubikmeter gas zum vergleich
deutschland verbraucht derzeit 90
milliarden pro jahr wovon nur etwa fünf
milliarden aus eigener förderung kommen
umweltverbände sind gegen die
erschließung des neuen feldes auch wegen
der nähe zum naturpark wattenmeer aber
niedersachsen hat jetzt grünes licht
gegeben peter kunst berichtet
der blick ins weite meer hier auf der
nordseeinsel borkum könnte künftig bei
gutem wetter an einer gasplattform
hängen bleiben 20 kilometer vor den
ferien strand soll sie stehen eher würde
ich hier keinen urlaub mehr machen mit
tut's weh dass dann die ganze umwelt
wieder hier in mitleidenschaft gezogen
ist der nationalpark wattenmeer die
umwelt die urlauber aus vielen gründen
waren die gas bohrpläne vor borkum
eigentlich begraben worden der ukraine
krieg hat sie wieder nach oben
geschwemmt vor dem hintergrund in der
völlig veränderten geopolitischen
realitäten muss die deutsche energie
versorgungssicherheit neu gedacht ja wir
sind natürlich enttäuscht wir reden von
erdbebengefahr von senkungen aber auch
von verschmutzung des wassers was dann
hier durch die strömung hergetragen wir
diese gründe sind nach wie vor da
nordsee gas spezialisten dafür sitzen in
den niederlanden das ist ein planungs
video der firma die als partner des
landes niedersachsen das
grenzüberschreitende gasreserve vor
borkum ausbeuten soll gebohrt wird von
niederländischen hoheitsgewässern
richtung insel ungefährlich für mensch
und natur beteuert der chef wir werden
mit striktesten deutschen und
niederländischen umweltstandards
produzieren environment zuständig wir
brauchen dieses gasfeld nicht erstens
ist es kontraproduktiv für den
klimaschutz jetzt wieder in die
gasförderung einzusteigen zweitens liegt
das feld am rande des weltnaturerbes
wattenmeer
stattdessen sollten wir jetzt einsteigen
in energiesparen gas vom ferienort für
eine russland unabhängige versorgung
bleibt das ein kleiner baustein während
unsere energie sorgen die aussicht auf
borkum sowieso schon verändert haben
nach einer reihe von skandalen muss
sachsens innenminister roland wöller von
der cdu nun seinen hut nehmen es hatte
vorwürfe von vetternwirtschaft gegeben
und immer neue vorfälle bei der
sächsischen polizei neuer innenminister
soll der derzeitige chef des bundesamtes
für bevölkerungsschutz und langjährige
cdu bundestagsabgeordnete armin schuster
werden cornelia schiemenz von franziska
wunderlich über die entlassung verlassen
paukenschlag in dresden der
ministerpräsident schmeißt seinen
innenminister hochkant aus dem abend
gerade mal drei minuten nahm sich
michael kretschmer heute dafür zeit
meine einschätzung dass es für die
zukunft richtig ist mit einem
personellen neuanfang mit kraft mit
neuen ideen und vor allen dingen mit
mehr und breiterem vertrauen an die
arbeit zu gehen roland wöller seit 2017
sächsischer innenminister
die liste der skandale ist lang
korruptionsvorwürfe bei der leipziger
polizei umstrittene demo einsätze
gestohlene munition zu fall brachte ihn
letztlich der jüngste vorwurf der
vetternwirtschaft
so soll wöller einer früheren
kommilitonen seiner frau einen posten an
der sächsischen polizei hochschule
verschafft haben die polizeigewerkschaft
kritisiert dass es immer weniger
kommunikation gegeben hat immer weniger
transparenz gegeben hat man hat er so
das gefühl gehabt als sich der minister
in seinem büro verschlossenheit und
personalentscheidung getroffen hat die
ja nicht abgesprochen hat roland wöller
war ein enger vertrauter von michael
kretschmer der rausschmiss heute
überfällig meint die opposition wenn
ministerpräsident ist natürlich nicht
ohne blessuren aus der sache raus
gekommen denn er hat sich ja erst es für
hinwil eingesetzt und er hat viel zu
lange an ihm festgehalten neuer
innenminister sachsen soll armin
schuster werden bislang leiter des
bundesamtes für bevölkerungsschutz und
katastrophenhilfe offizielle anwendung
am montag
das berliner landgericht hat heute den
parteiausschluss des früheren
brandenburger fdp chefs andreas kalbitz
bestätigt campbell soll bei seinem
eintritt in die partei 2013 eine frühere
mitgliedschaft in der inzwischen
verbotenen rechtsextremen heimattreuen
deutschen jugend sowie bei den
republikanern nicht angegeben haben die
fdp hatte ihm daher die
parteimitgliedschaft entzogen cables
klage dagegen wurde jetzt in erster
instanz abgewiesen
diese messerattacke löste letzten sommer
bundesweit entsetzen aus in einem
kaufhaus in würzburg fragt ein mann nach
einem küchenmesser dann sticht er
wahllos auf menschen in seiner nähe ein
fünf minuten später sind drei frauen tot
neun weitere menschen überleben teils
schwer verletzt seit heute steht er
offenbar psychisch kranke täter aus
somalia vor gericht petra neubauer hat
den prozess verfolgt
der mann aus somalia wirkt zu
prozessauftakt ein wenig verloren
verhandelt wird aus platzgründen in
einem riesigen konferenzzentrum es geht
um mord und versuchten mord aber auch um
eine mögliche schuldunfähigkeit des
mannes
das heißt aber nicht dass man auf die
taten die er begangen haben soll
überhaupt nicht reagieren kann sondern
es gibt die möglichkeit der dauerhaften
unterbringung des beschuldigten in einem
psychiatrischen krankenhaus
am nachmittag des 25
juni 2021 soll der beschuldigte ihn und
vor einem würzburger kaufhaus mit einem
messer mehrfach auf andere eingestochen
haben passanten versuchen ihn in schach
zu halten dennoch drei frauen sterben
neun weitere menschen werden verletzt
laut staatsanwaltschaft wollte der mann
seinen willkürlich ausgesuchten opfern
keine chance lassen doch warum das alles
passt oder gegebenenfalls religiöse
motive oder ob gegebenenfalls die
psychische erkrankung des beschuldigten
eine rolle gespielt hat muss im rahmen
der hauptverhandlung geklärt werden der
mann der 2015 nach deutschland kam war
schon mehrmals in psychiatrischer
behandlung nimmt medikamente
terroristische hintergründe schließt ein
verteidiger kategorisch aus die taten
ein er weiß dass er schreckliches leid
über viele personen gebracht hat und er
hat auch geäußert dass stimmen ihnen
dazu gedrängt haben also ganz
offensichtlich eine psychose
vorherrschend gewesen war ob auch das
gericht dieser sichtweise folgt und eine
womöglich lebenslange unterbringung in
einer geschlossenen einrichtung anordnet
soll in 27 verhandlungstagen entschieden
werden
das jahr 20 21 und das haben wir jetzt
auch amtlich war in europa ein jahr der
extreme das belegen aktuelle klimadaten
der eu so war der sommer der wärmste
seit beginn der aufzeichnungen vor über
40 jahren rekordhitze beispielsweise in
italien
in der folge konnten sich waldbrände
dort aber auch in griechenland und der
türkei rasant ausbreiten auf der anderen
seite gab es im sommer 20 21 aber auch
starkregen und überflutungen wert wir in
belgien und in deutschland
im bezirk formel 1 norbert und zum
großen preis der indianer in imola ein
heimspiel also für ferrari die scuderia
ist ja mit zwei siegen in dieser
wm-saison gestartet dank schal erklärt
dem führenden in der gesamtwertung der
musste aber nach einem turbulenten
qualifying weltmeister max verstappen
die pole position überlassen
mal regnet es mal nicht auch weltmeister
max verstappen rutscht von der strecke
der niederländer schon zweimal nicht im
ziel in dieser saison ist minuten vor
dem ende der qualifikation schneller als
der wm-führende le claire der im ferrari
dann die letzte chance sucht dem aber
nach zwei siegen in drei rennen bislang
die zeit fehlt letztlich um verstappen
in der quali noch zu übertreffen
sebastian vettel geht als guter neunter
in das erste von drei sprintrennen der
saison morgen in imola max verstappen
steht da auf startplatz eins
deutschlands handball frauen haben sich
mit einem rekordsieg für die
europameisterschaft qualifiziert das
team des neuen bundestrainers markus
gaugisch besiegte außenseiter griechen
dann klar mit 40 zu 11 so ein baby
wünscht man sich als bundestrainer eine
mannschaft mit biss und spielwitz war da
auf dem platz beim qualifikationsspiel
in mehreren niederlande gegen insgesamt
schwach agierende griechen die deutschen
in weiß in allen belangen eindeutig
überlegen beste werferinnen waren
johanna stockschläger mit 6 und
kapitänin alina grätzels mit fünf
treffern die einseitige partie
allerdings kein maßstab im testspiel am
samstag warten starken niederländerinnen
überraschungs sieg der bayern im playoff
viertelfinale der basketball euroleague
nach der heimniederlage gelangen den
starken münchner beim fc barcelona im
zweiten von fünf möglichen partien ein
souveränes 90 75 bester werfer bei den
bayern die schon thomas mit 25 punkten
und sechs von sieben verwandelten dreier
versuchen
das was im sport danken aber man wird
schauen noch kurz aufs wetter denn da
tut sich was während es zuletzt
besonders im nordosten trüb war mit
etwas regen scheint morgen dort die
sonne und im süden der würzburger mehr
gleich von katja honnefer das heute
schon mal können sie um 22 uhr sehen mit
bettina schausten schön freitagabend
noch
[Musik]
guten abend während über nordeuropa die
hochs dominieren ziehen die tiefs über
südeuropa und kommen uns von süden und
von südwesten
deswegen wird das wetter zumindest in
süddeutschland wechselhafter das tief
über italien brachte heute aber nicht
nur wolken und regen mit sondern auch
saharastaub sie sehen dass hier an
dieser leichten luft trübung das tief
hat aber noch mehr auswirkungen auf
unser wetter denn in der nacht gibt's
dichtere wolken hier in sachsen und in
bayern und da kann es auch mal leicht
regnen in norddeutschland ist es klar
und die temperaturen sinken hier rund um
berlin auf 3 bis 2 grad milder bleibt es
im westen zum beispiel im rhein main
gebiet mit neun grad am morgen liegen
die höchsttemperaturen zwischen 11 grad
auf rügen und 20 grad am rhein und in
norddeutschland strahlt morgen die sonne
meist vom blauen himmel es gibt nur
wenige harmlose wolken und dazu wie der
wind aus östlichen richtungen in
süddeutschland verdichten sich die
wolken mehr und mehr und am nachmittag
kann es dann im südwesten und auch aus
den alpen heraus einige regenschauer und
gewitter geben regen und gewitter weiten
sich dann am sonntag weiter nach norden
aus die küste werden sie wohl nicht
erreichen die temperaturen am sonntag
liegen zwischen 9 und 17 grad guten
abend